So it's a little convoluted, but it really does work and it's the best way that I've
found to get around coop headers. Go hack on things you're not supposed to.
Go find access on third parties. Leverage the third party trust relationship.
Best path of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
Oh, yeah, dude.
Already, I've been telling you for the past couple of weeks about Threat Locker Detect, right?
Bunch of cool logging, a bunch of cool remediation methods that that built in right into that
automation in the Threat Locker Detect system. But at the end of the day, there's nothing quite like
having a human in the loop for these sort of incidents. And back when I was a consultant,
you know, one of the techniques that we would use pretty often was if we had a team that was
pretty active in incident response, like they were fighting us as we were trying to get into the
systems, we would just switch to nights because nobody feels like getting their butt out of bed
and going to the computer and fighting off the red team, right in the middle of the night.
And so that worked a lot of the time. But Threat Locker's got your back in a situation just like
this as well, because they've got a product, an add on for their Threat Locker Detect system
called Cyber Hero Manage Detect and Response. And this employs a 24-7 monitoring service of
cyber heroes that are there to fight off attackers in your network, which one sounds hella intimidating,
and two, makes sense that you would want a human in the loop there. And yeah, what a lot of people
don't realize too, is there's time zones, right? So it could be the middle of the day for someone in
Asia, it'd be middle of the night here, you know, in the US. So it's really important to have someone
24-7 kind of working on those systems to defend it. And Threat Locker has got your back with that,
with their MDR product. All right, cool. Let's go back to the show.
All right, my dude, first day of full-time bug bounty and freedom from the nine to five. How are
you feeling? I feel good. Yeah. And we got to announce that I'm the new co-host today,
which is pretty sick. Got to post that everywhere and it's popping off, but no, I'm excited to be here.
I mean, I hope that I can pull off the goal of finding a bug today on day one. Obviously,
you, uh, they pulled me away from the computer for a little while here today, but it's worth it.
Yeah, man, dude, I don't know what's up this morning, but my shoulder is like
hacked up from volleyball. Last night, dude was like some of the best volleyball I've ever played.
Like I just, we like the rest of our team wasn't there. So we were actually five versus six.
And there's something about being like five versus six that just makes you kind of go into over
overdrive mode. You know what I'm saying? Is it like an actual match, like one V one where you
advance or you get a win loss and everything? Yeah, we, we played like three rounds, um,
like three games to 25 and then we do it again. So it's like six games in total. Um, and it just
continues to your overall score. But dude, yesterday I was just crushing the spikes and it just, my arms
feeling it a little bit today though. Yeah. I was looking around on the ground. Cause I was thinking
about the Nito. We, we, uh, found out that both you and I, uh, like our Nito as our little fidget, uh,
thing, cause you were using it in the last episode. I freaking love this thing, dude. I'm like, I, I,
I think got one and, uh, and literally like I, I saw it and I'm like, oh my gosh, this thing is
amazing. I started playing with it. I never gave it back to her. They got me like six for Christmas.
So that's amazing. I don't know what it is about it. Like it's definitely a, a really unique feel.
If I I'm sure, honestly, we already know a lot of our listeners have either ADHD or some form of autism.
If they, if you need a fidget thing, this it's called Nito. It's really interesting. It definitely
feels like cooler and better than any kind of other squish toy. It's also, it's also pretty
freaking good for just like, um, just an, a hand exercise too. Like you like it'll,
I tell you that I kind of want to do that for getting better grips and BJJ. I was already thinking
about that if I just do it enough, but anyways, dude, I, I rolled for the first time in like a couple
months, like two weeks ago. And it just, dude, I, it just so reinvigorated. I got it. I
gotta get out there. I gotta get in the gym for that dude. Uh, it's, it's just so behind my, uh,
quarterly goal along with playing video games and watching more YouTube. So when I hit my quarterly
bug bounty goal, it unlocks all of those things. Well, I, I liked, I liked what, um, what, who was
it? Was it Douglas? What Douglas said is like, you know, offsetting your goal, um, with your like
professional goal with like, uh, no, no, there was James kettle, James kettle posted about it. He said,
he said, um, I don't think I should have like a professional goal and then a, uh, like a non-professional
goal that you kind of pair. So he's like, I want to like get my research in DEFCON or whatever. And I
also want to like do a three times body weight deadlift. I'm like, oh shit, dude, like a three
times body weight deadlift is like pretty freaking good. It's pretty intense. Yeah. I, I've always had
really strong legs. Uh, for me, I would try, I'd maybe try to do a three times body weight or maybe two
and a half times body weight squat or something, but oh my God, dude, are you serious? That's not
good. I don't know if I could, but I think it'd be interesting to try. Yeah, that's for sure.
Yeah. Deadlift is definitely better for me. My legs are a little weak, but, uh, but the back kind of
makes up for it. So yeah, nice anyway. All right. So, so we did our, we did, we did a little,
we did a little off track right at right in the beginning. Um, we got some news today, a little bit
of stuff from me, a little bit of stuff from you. And then we're going to talk about,
um, web header stuff, which, uh, yeah, it seems like you're very prepared on Joseph.
Yeah. We'll talk about that in a little bit, but I'm going to, uh, play as a listener maybe. So we'll
see. Okay. We, we, um, you know, Joseph is, is new to the, to the co-host thing and we had the doc
sectioned out and he like did all of this thorough research on the news section. And then I was like,
so what'd you think of the, the web headers section? And he's like the, who, what section?
So I will say, listen, I've been a guest on critical thinking. I, and I've got for one or two
episodes in an, every one, all of the stuff's in the news section. It's all just been right there.
There's been no main content. So.
All good, man. It happens. Plus, you know, I'm, I'm used to just yapping about client side stuff. So,
I get it. All right. Let me, let me hit the first news item then. Uh, this was just a really
like feel good, feel good story that I saw. Um, this is from, uh, I grabbed this one actually from
LinkedIn, uh, from Dustin Kirkland. And he posted about, uh, an article entitled a proud dad's tale of two
bug hunting daughters in their responsible disclosure. And when I saw this dude, I was
like, ah, my heart is so warmed. And I was, I was reading through here and his daughters found two
bugs on the like parental controls aspect of Google. One was like a, um, you know, you could reuse
those like, uh, codes that you give to the child to unlock the device. Yeah. And then the other one
was like on, on their like Chromecast or Google TV, they just mashed the home button and they bypassed the
parental controls. It just put them right into the parent account, which is like totally nuts.
Yeah. Yeah. When you sent me that and I clicked on it, first of all, the picture,
the header picture is like so cute. So hopefully people either tune into the YouTube channel and we
have our producer, add that in there, or they go to the blog post. But, um, but yeah, I mean,
obviously we have young kids, both you and I. And so it just warms the heart, but yeah, totally
impressive. I mean, and they both got paid like no better way to, uh, set them up for financial
success from throwing that into, uh, you know, the Roth IRA is like a eight year old.
Oh yeah. And then for sure. And then what did it like, I want to say down here at the end,
where did she say, uh, she said it was, it was the first daughter. Yeah. Oh, was it the first
daughter that was like, I want to invest it in my, in the stock market. Yeah. She says, uh, I asked her,
what did she want to do with it? And she says, invested in the stock market, dad. And I was just like,
could you imagine raising them? Well, that's for sure. So cute, man. So cute. And yeah,
I think it's, I think it's really cool to share the hacking stuff with your kids. You know, um,
I know that I've, I've hacked with, with my, with my kid and, uh, it's been a nice experience. Um,
at least just be able to talk about like, yeah, I know a little bit about hacking and even if it's
not your thing, it's still cool to be able to say like, yeah, I understand what my dad does and, and,
uh, and can talk about it a little bit and say, they have some experience with it.
Yeah. Yeah. So with my oldest daughter, she's eight, but I think it was probably when she was seven.
She told me that at school to log into some app, they are some website they use, they type in their,
uh, classrooms number, like either their classroom number or their teacher's name or something.
But yeah, she told me that instead she typed in our, oh yeah, they type in their classroom number,
but instead she typed in our phone number and there wasn't even enough digits for it. It was like six
digits instead of eight or 10 or whatever phone numbers are. And it brought up a somewhat like a
different class and she could see other students information in there. And when she got home and
told me this, I like just lit up. I was so pumped and told her that she had found her first bug and
made a big deal out of it. And then whenever hacker one had like the family kind of event, uh, in
Orlando last January, they were down there and she was going around telling all the other bug hunters
and telling all the staff about the bugs she found. I would have a retell the stories though.
Yeah. Dude, that's so cute, man. Yeah. Those kid oriented apps are like wicked insecure sometimes.
And I get it. Cause you gotta like make it easy enough for like a kid to be able to log in and
stuff like that. But like, also why don't you just not put all the kids PII at risk?
Exactly. Yeah. When it's school related. It's yeah.
Yeah. And, and, and I guess like, I don't know if you're like a motivated
attacker trying to go after kids or something like that, maybe you could figure it out. But most of
the time you're not even going to see it unless you've got a kid and you're like, oh yeah, they're
logging into this portal or whatever. So I don't know, but it's definitely a little bit insecure.
I have to say most of those kid oriented apps that I've seen.
Yeah. I mean all the different stuff for like kids sports and for like their fundraisers and all those,
I mean, I've probably put our information in, I don't know, 20 different sites that I'm
terrified. Yeah. They're like very vulnerable, very insecure, but yeah.
Solid dude. All right. What you, what have you got on your side? You'd want to talk about H1 and BC
pen tests? Yeah. So I put down on this news list just for the listeners. Um, because I actually
haven't heard you or Joel mention it too much. It might've been mentioned in passing, but both
hacker one and bug crowd have a notion of pen test. I don't, they've kind of iterated and changed
through the years. Hacker one pen tests are pretty cool. They're like in standard and then premium.
Um, you don't get paid for findings on those. I remember there were some on bug crowd in the
past. I don't know if it still works this way where you could get paid a flat fee and then you
also got paid for the vulnerabilities, which was pretty cool. And that's how, um, and I guess just,
yeah, as an addendum to that, not only are there hacker one and bug crowd pen tests, but also Google
will sometimes do research grants where it's similar. You get paid a flat fee, but you still get, um, paid for
all of the bugs that you submit and you have to go in and enable that on your profile. So if anybody has,
is interested in that, go to your Google bug hunters profile and make sure you enable it,
that you're open to it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And so you have to like go in there on bug hunters.google.com,
go to your profile, scroll down. And I think there's like a little toggle button that says like
enable research grants. And I'm like, dang, that should be public, man. Like, like, or that should
be on by default. Like, like that would be great if people just all of a sudden like, boom, here's the
money in your bank. Now go hack on this. Yeah, exactly. You do have to go and accept it and all
that. So, yeah. Yeah. Um, but yeah, I, there's also some, I want to, I'm trying to remember who
told me about it. It was another top hacker recently told me a bet that they were doing some pen tests.
I want to say it's with integrity. I don't know. Um, but it was $500 flat and you get paid for
the bucks. Right. And I'm like, and you know, anybody who's done these pen tests before it's
like, I don't know, man, pen tests are such a different world than bug bounty. It's like,
there's just bugs fricking everywhere. Yeah. Very frequently, especially if it's one of their first
few. Yeah, exactly. And so, and so, um, yeah, to be honest, I think I'd be a little bit more in
favor of like the flat rate plus bounties rather than just the, you know, higher flat rate. So.
Yeah. And I think a lot of it depends on like the hours that are expected there. Um, you know, if,
if it's kind of like, make sure you've tested everything, um, you know, with like a baseline
pass, that's much more reasonable than like a, you know, a kind of lowest rate for a bunch of hours.
So. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Dude, I've really enjoyed the Google one too. Like you and I both got
some research grants with Google lately and they've just been, they've been really great. It's just,
they're so fun to work with dude, to be honest, like, because they will help you exploit bugs. Um,
really, really nice, really good. Yeah. Very communicative. Yeah. Very easy to work with.
Yeah. All right. Let, let, let me jump over to my next news item, which was Truffle sec released a new,
um, a new article talking about, uh, OAuth bugs that affect millions of accounts. Um, particularly
Google's OAuth login. And I was clicking through here cause I've been really interested in OAuth lately.
And, um, uh, and we're going to do an episode on OAuth in a couple of weeks, uh, after this episode
airs. Um, but this one was, was interesting. Uh, he, he does kind of break down the specific details
of it, but the TLDR of it is kind of like, if a startup fails, you can register the domain and then
SSO into all these services, which like, there's totally not necessarily always failing. It could be
they changed their domain. Like they bought a new one, they migrated. There's lots of maybe other
use cases or other examples there. Yeah. I think the coolest part about this piece of research was
the proposed fix that they, that they had that where they were, um, talking about implementing
two immutable, uh, identifiers in the open ID connect flow. Um, and I think Google may, is considering
this. They said at the end of the day, they awarded a $1,337 bounty. And then it seems like they'll
be making some changes. So I think that's cool. But I think this really also makes me think of the
episode with, um, like the top bugs, uh, from 2024, from the, uh, the hackers and
Knobly mentioned on that episode that they used a, uh, like a dev token to get into an Azure environment.
And then once they were in the Azure environment, they dumped all the users and then, uh, looked at
all the domains that are registrable or register, double registratable, register, double, register,
double, dude. I swear sometimes like much, the ego got cheated. Um, my English just dies dude. Um,
but yeah, they, they looked for all the domains that were, that were registrable and then registered
one and then use that to escalate their privileges. So I think that whole, I don't know, man, I don't
know what I think about that concept because I think it goes a little bit outside the realm of
like normal bug bounty flow. Um, but man, the impact is high a lot of times. So yeah. Yeah.
It stood out to me that this is often not, I mean, companies where this would be impactful are already
defunct. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Who's gonna pay you for this? Well, but, but at the same time, there is
impact there because like, um, they mentioned this thing, you know, millions of people's data is
accessible through these third party SAS providers. Honestly, it's a little bit of like a SAS security or I
guess maybe cloud security issue, right? Because, um, with the single sign on, once you get access
to the account, you can get access to everything else. And yeah, I really loved that part of
Nagly's bug and it actually makes me wonder, but also probably believe that other username
disclosures might actually have slightly more impact if there's something like this possible. So.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and I think the way that this would apply to bug bounty is, is like you said,
you know, the, the companies that are being like attacked here are mostly what
they're talking about here is, is personal user information and information that are in those
systems. Right. But, um, I think that it's most applicable in the way that Nagly did it.
Right. Which is you have XYZ company, uh, that you're, that you're attacking, right. And XYZ company
contracts out to ABC company, ABC company goes under, right. You, you grab the domain and then single
sign on into like some part of XYZ company, the first company, and then get access to like their
internal Slack or their JIRA or whatever. Um, but, but to be able to get that level of insight one,
you have to know what companies this, this company is contracting with. Right. And then you've also got
to understand, um, you know, what systems that, that contracting company will have access to on your
target company. So there's a lot of recon, the pretty heavy recon that needs to go into place there,
but I could definitely see this being super useful for those targets where it's like, Hey, get this,
this, you know, get this flag that's in this like deep embedded system. And we don't care how you do
it. As long as you get the flag, you get the money and then you kind of go through this route.
Yeah. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get
the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able
to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able
to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get
the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get
the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money.
And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money
to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able
to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money.
And then you're going to be able to get the money. And then you're going to be able to get the money.
And then you're going to be able to get the money.
How am I going to hack AI agents in the future? Because there's going to be a bunch of new companies that are going to get bug bounty programs that are offering AI agent type support.
How can I hack on my existing programs, which are already implementing AI agents on the backside?
Like what kind of bug could be there? And then if people like building stuff, like how can I build some sort of like AI agent security product, whether it's that offlay or other stuff?
So I just wanted to bring that up because I think it's blowing up in the industry and it's on people's mind.
There's a lot of that, man. Yeah, for sure. And it's definitely like we were talking about before the episode ran.
I think it's a space where it's a very good niche.
If you are looking for an area where you want to specialize in hacking stuff and you just want to make good money on that, you want to be a high paid consultant, that sort of thing.
Or, you know, there's an episode that I'm thinking about doing, which I won't give away too much on.
But essentially it's an episode around like what I call the AJX Chapman method, which is you like deep specialize on one specific thing.
And how do you do that? And what areas would be a good place to specialize?
I think this makes the list, you know, because whenever you see weaponized agents, you know, agents that have functionality to them that are of the ability to take action.
You know, that's a specialized technology that you have to know how to attack.
So, so, I mean, let me ask you this, dude. What what are what do you think are like?
Okay, let me just draw the correlation back to the the AJX Chapman sort of thing, right?
You know, people hit Alex Chapman up when they see a headless browser.
Yep. Headless browser, XSSRC, you gotta get it.
Exactly. You get that sort of headless browser type environment.
So what is the the user agent Chrome, right, of these AI agent things?
What are the things that you should see that make you say, okay, hey, I should get this to an expert or I should deep dive on it?
Or I should deep dive on this because there's more functionality here that I need to know how to attack at like a deeper level.
Yeah, I think that makes sense. Yeah, it does. That's basically the question I was asking Johan in that episode of people want to go back and listen to that.
But like in general, it's just like if it can do anything interesting with data or tools, that's why that's what I find super interesting.
And I think that that level of functionality is a is a target rich environment because it's it is kind of annoying to hack sometimes because you have to convince the system to use it.
You want to use the payload you want to use. Yeah. But also port speakers labs on that are really good. Right.
It's like you're telling an agent to call a tool with a payload and you can tell it to use a apostrophe or you can tell it to use open and close square brackets.
You can tell it to like use other users IDs. Right. There's like a there's kind of a rich attack surface there.
But yeah, I mean, I think it's a strong niche, even if you don't like interacting with LLMs.
Like I don't want everyone to think like, oh, you know, I don't want to be the LLM hacker guy.
And it and LLMs can be annoying because of the non determinism there.
But I think in this in this agent security space, we need people who are like working on like kind of the sandbox and like the sandbox escapes.
We need people who are like tackling the prompt injection and jailbreak side of things.
We need people who are like thinking through the safety thing.
So I think that there's a lot of different areas you can specialize in.
But yeah, in general, I would say if there's a chatbot or an feature that has like a lot of tools or like some interesting or deep tools and if the dual and if the tools have access to any kind of data like you just when you're chatting with chatbots, ask like, hey, what do you know about me?
What can you tell about myself? Because if it has a lot of information about you, then someone could leak that probably about you with certain different techniques.
There was a challenge we were given by a target recently, and I think the way that they outlined what they were looking for with these attacks was super good.
They were like, hey, you know, it needs to start with some sort of indirect prompt injection.
So there has to be some tool that is grabbing your data as the attacker and then putting it into the prompt. Right.
So, you know, then they've got an array of tools that they can do that with.
And then from there, you need to establish control of the LLM prompt. Right.
And then once you've established control of the LLM prompt, you need to either get X, Y, Z.
Right. You either get persistence on the system.
You affect the user's data in a negative way, in a way that's not undoable, you know, that causes permanent data loss or permanent data effect.
Or leak their data. Yeah.
Yeah. Or leak the data back out. Right.
So I think that's a good, like, just quick and easy three step process. Right.
Establish some reasonable method for prompt injection. Right.
Indirect prompt injection or prompt injection.
Establish control of the prompt. Right.
And, you know, gain control of the LLM.
And then utilize that control to either leak or affect user data or gain persistence in the LLM moving forward.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Good stuff.
Pretty, pretty solid.
Um, okay, cool.
So, uh, dude, let me, let me hop into this next, this next, dude, now I'm all hype on AI stuff.
Now I got to change.
I got to change.
Uh, well, actually, dude, since we're talking about AI stuff, what is this rank thing that you had from Bishop Fox?
Yeah. So, um, I'm sure most people know of an operator.
I have found out before the episode that you're also friends with mineral life, which is cool.
Dude, he rocks, man.
But, um, so yeah, he wrote this, uh, thing you all can find in the show notes it's called rank, but spelled with an I.
So it's AI, uh, within the middle of the word rank.
Um, and so one thing you often want to do when you're hacking in general, it's like, what assets should I look at first?
Right. Which domain is most interesting, which payload is most likely to work?
They're like humans kind of figure out, you know, um, what we're going to do first by kind of ranking them in our head and then just like going down that list with AI.
Sometimes that's hard to get them to like, um, that's not hard to get them to, you can just ask them to list them.
But it's hard to get, uh, AI output to be ranked in a meaningful way based on a specific heuristic that you want and to not repeat itself and that sort of thing.
And so they found some cool ways to, I haven't dug into how all of the different ways they use them, but they wrote an open source project where you can have AI rank a list of anything.
And so I think for the security implications, they are pretty cool.
The ones I just mentioned, you know, ranking the best payload we use or the most likely to use or the website that's most likely to be vulnerable, et cetera.
There are probably a lot of different use cases here, but I think you went to the talk where they actually use this to find some bugs with called patch perfect.
It was, it was really cool when you, when this showed up in my docs, because one I'm like buddies with Caleb.
He's like, he's like, uh, I knew him even, even before the security community, we just met through a mutual friend.
And, um, and then it was, it was kind of crazy.
I don't know if I've talked about this story on the pod before, but like I met him through a mutual friend, right?
And my mutual friend was like, Hey, you know, you're a hacker.
He's a hacker.
And I'm like, okay, cool.
Yeah, sure.
And then I meet him and he's like this super bad-ass dude.
Like, uh, and so, cause like, there's so many people out there that are like, yeah, I'm a hacker.
And they like, you know, they work in security and it's like, you know, okay, cool.
You know, you are a hacker, but it doesn't mean that you're doing like hands on the keyboard, you know, POC or GTFO popping shit all day, every day sort of hacker.
Right.
Um, that is definitely Caleb, you know?
And so like when I met him, I was like, oh shit, he's the real deal.
Um, and so anyway, I, I, you know, we've got a local conference here in Richmond called RVASec.
And, uh, you know, Caleb being the inspiration that he is decides to support the local, local conference.
And present his talk there.
Um, and so I, so I was there, you know, just chilling and watching this, this talk.
And, uh, it was really good.
It was, it was entitled to patch perfect harmonizing with LLMs to find security volumes, which I loved, you know, cause I'm a big, I'm a musical, musical boy.
Pitch perfect.
We listened to that soundtrack for like years after he came out.
Freaking good, man.
I'm like, I'm, I'm a little bit scared of that movie because if I listen, if I watch it again, it's going to get all the ear bugs.
I'm just going to be singing nonstop for the past or for the foreseeable future.
But, um, the talk was really good in, in how they use sort of like this ranking sort of thing to identify, uh, the most likely functions in a, in a, um, binary diff of a patch.
Yeah.
That contained the vulnerability and, uh, give the, the researcher that's trying to reverse a patch, a headstart on where the vulnerability lies.
That's really cool.
Um, and, and the results were pretty impressive.
Like they're able to get it down, um, to like 10% of all the, the diffed functions with really, really high accuracy.
The function that has the vulnerability is within this top 10%, which saves you, you know, 90% of time.
So definitely lots of good, um, lots of good applications for this across security.
And it's nice to have a tool that, that automatically does it.
Yeah.
That's legit.
You want to tell us about this, uh, gift card research?
Oh yeah.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
Um, our boy w two w, uh, a, uh, a member of the full-time hunters guild, by the way, shout out to my man, um, dropped some research called gift card security research.
And I just wanted to, to, um, to shout this one out.
We'll, um, we'll link it in the description as always, but let me go ahead and share my screen as well for those, for those folks on YouTube.
Um, this research was awesome.
Uh, because once again, it's just a time when somebody says, Hey, I'm going to research this specific bone class or this specific niche.
Mm-hmm and they do it across a lot of targets and they record the results.
I'm such a sucker for that stuff, man.
That's the stuff, the stuff that, um, that freaking, uh, bug bounty reports explained does on their like premium newsletter subscription, where you'll just get like these super data rich analyses on types of vulnerabilities.
And it's just so insightful into the way that you should look at these vulnerable classes.
Um, yeah.
So, anyway, sometimes in your own life, like with the credit card research.
So, oh, oh, a hundred percent.
Yeah.
And, and, um, it's very applicable.
And definitely worth whatever I pay for bug bounty reports explained premium for sure.
Um, but this one, w two w gives us, uh, for free.
And he says, I acquired 30 plus gift cards on this research.
And revealed the nine vulnerabilities by unlocking new features, which granted me $6,500.
Um, and let me see how many bugs he's got here.
I think nine different bugs.
Um, and there were three primary bone classes that popped out of this.
There was race condition.
There was HTML injection or XSS and, uh, IDOR.
And I just wanted to echo this as well, because my personal experience has really, um, aligned with this research that, uh, anytime I've bought gift cards, there's either a race condition or an IDOR.
I don't know what it is, but it just always is.
Every time.
Um, yeah.
And, and so, uh, I think that's a pretty target rich, um, and attack factor rich environment.
And you can sometimes get a gift card for like five bucks.
So it's definitely worth the investment.
Yeah.
I mean, anytime you can get access to like a little more scope, a few more API calls and like working ones too, right?
If you have the gift card, you're actually gonna be able to actually purchase something.
You'll be able to actually enable it.
It gives you access to a bunch of like either new domains or new paths that are actually working for you.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
And then, so, you know, those are the three main goal types that he, he found, um, the specific research.
And then I wanted to also just shout out this last tip at the very end.
He doesn't, he doesn't talk about this too much in the actual, um, article, but he says at the end, final thoughts, he says, ensure you enable out of scope logging and all mine types in your, uh, minimum proxy, uh, to catch the checkout finalization request.
I wasted quite a few gift cards to learn this lesson.
It doesn't hurt when it's a $5 gift card, but it's a big ouch moment when it's a $50 gift card.
Um, so yeah, I totally agree.
Like going through that full process and just literally intercepting everything and going through each request being like, is this a good idea?
Yeah.
And then I went back and I, and the data was like, oh, yeah, I'm going to go to the right now.
And then I'm going to go to the right now, but Kaido doesn't have currently a way to set logging to none for stuff.
You can't, you can't just drop requests.
They get stored.
Right.
Yeah.
They always get stored.
And, and you know, that blows up your hard drive space a little bit, but storage is cheap.
And you know what is not cheap?
Not having the piece of information that you need.
And so there, there've been many times where I've been like, ah, dude, that S3 bucket or like, oh man, this is, this functionality is getting pushed out to a third party.
And then I went back and I, and the data was there and I was like, frick.
Yeah.
So, I mean, that, that alone has made me several thousand dollars.
I think, um, uh, you know, just having that forced me to be a little bit more permissive with what, what I'm storing.
And that's the same sort of thing we talked about last year when, when mayonnaise came on the, on the pod where he literally has never, uh, not had every single, he's never gotten rid of any piece of data related to a bug bounty target ever.
And he's just got it all in a big database and he just does big data queries against it, you know, and he's just uncovers these trends across targets and, and across the same target.
So definitely, definitely a, a useful piece of functionality, I think.
For sure.
And then I think the one last thing we wanted to mention it's on your list, but I can kick us off on it.
Is that the, um, top 10 voting for, from port swigger, um, is now out.
And not only is it a huge treasure trove of data, but our listeners probably care deeply about who wins.
Cause there's a lot of our listeners who are on this list.
Right.
And so there are, make sure you go out and support the, uh, the, your fellow hackers by voting for their research if you like it.
And, um, it's a fantastic way to go back and learn what you missed or see what you missed from, um, as far as like cool hacks go from last year.
Absolutely.
There are a lot of, um, uh, CTBB podcast guests that have their, their data out here, um, uh, in this up for rating.
So, uh, that's, that's pretty rad.
Definitely, definitely, like you said, a good place to see the research that you missed great research that you missed, but also just to support the fellow hacker.
I can't help, but ask you, do you have any idea why there's one that says do not vote for the century?
Dude, I saw that.
I just saw that as I'm scrolling through there.
I don't know, but dude, you know, that's gonna get so many votes.
For sure.
It's gonna get so many votes.
Don't do that guys.
Come on.
Don't waste your vote.
Give some valid research the vote, please.
That's true.
Um, solid.
All right, man.
Cool.
So now the time has come to talk about web headers.
Yeah.
Ready for this?
The topic I did not know, uh, what we were even discussing today.
So yes, I will play the ignorant, uh, listener and also in general, you know, my specialty is not in front and stuff.
It's definitely been server side bugs and kind of a big fuzzing.
And then obviously AI of late.
So this is stuff that I've been wanting to dig into, and this has given me an excuse to learn about it.
So, um, when I don't understand something that a lot of listeners probably don't either.
And so I'll be sure to ask that.
Yeah, dude, uh, ask away and I'll do my best to articulate it all.
Um, so yeah, what we're talking about today is cross origin headers, which is like a suite of headers, cross origin opener policy, cross origin and better policy cross origin research policy.
I'm sorry, resource policy and, um, how these specific headers apply to the browser and how to get around them.
And unfortunately I have to say guys.
It's, it's rough.
It's rough out there.
There's not a lot of ways to get around these things.
Um, so, but I'm going to give you my best, my best takes on it.
And, um, uh, we, we have a little bit of research from the, the, um, critical research lab, which is, uh, the team that we kind of put together to try to try to give us cool pieces of, of information about this.
Uh, and, and also I'll just kind of, you know, talk to you about how these headers are actually used.
Yeah.
So question with this Andrew lock link at the top, I think you're going to talk about, did you learn anything new?
Like, did you learn any, uh, kind of potential bypasses or gadgets as you went through this?
Yeah.
So I think the Andrew lock article is really, which we'll link in the, in the description, but also just go ahead and.
And share on the screen.
Now.
Um, it's sort of like a three part blog post on these cross origin headers.
Uh, it's entitled understanding cross origin security headers.
So he does part one on a coop, which is the main culprit, the one that we hate.
Uh, and then there's a part two on cross origin, uh, resource policy, which is an interesting one.
And then we've got cross origin and better policy as well.
So these are definitely, if you're looking to sort of skill up on this area, um, these are great.
I think this came out in November of last year, but yeah, there was definitely some things that I learned about here that, um, I didn't know before.
So definitely, definitely worth a read.
Um, if you're trying to skill up there, uh, but also try to give you the TLDR today.
Yeah.
Um, and see how we can, we can do that.
So, um, first this, this whole set of headers and this whole concept is, uh, related to a browser concept called cross origin isolation.
Um, and this is a, a concept, uh, that was recently put into the browsers to kind of help deal with the specter, uh, attacks that were happening.
Um, that, that allowed you to violate same origin policy.
Um, and if you opt into these cross origin headers, you get some of the features back that they had to remove to, to help, um, deal with the specter attacks.
Um, and there's, uh, uh, JavaScript, you know, window property called, uh, cross origin isolated, and it's a Boolean true or false.
And it tells us whether in this specific context are, is this, this frame, this, this window, is it cross origin isolated or not?
Um, so that's, that's something that I didn't even know existed, uh, but is, but is actually in place.
What are some examples for why you would want to not isolate an origin or why?
And then when, when you would.
Yeah. So, so if you're trying to isolate an origin, it provides an extra layer of security, but also there are reasons to not do it. Right.
If you need to communicate with a, a different tab, um, via like a window dot opener relationship or something like that via post message or, or whatever, then you can't really isolate yourself because there has to be a relationship between those two tabs in the browser context group.
Um, and so that's.
If you're looking for a new app or to open a new window for you to like log in or do an off flow or do something and then it needs to pass something back to the first tab.
They could not use this feature.
Right.
Exactly. And, and that's, that's something you often see with off flows is like, is like, um, you know, you're handing it off either to a third party or to a same.
Same something on your same site. Right. Which is like, you know, uh, off dot domain.com going back to www dot domain.com. Right. The site is the same, but the origin is different.
Yeah. Um, uh, where it starts to get a little tricky. And so the main header that, that, that just really tweaks my melon, Joseph, I like, they really just hex up some great exploits is, uh, the cross origin opener policy or coop. Okay.
So let me, let me sort of, let me rant on this one for a second. Okay. Coop, this son of a badger is, uh, really messing up some stuff. Uh, because what, what often happens in a, when we're trying to exploit post message related bugs, which is like one of my bread and butter vulnerabilities is we need to open up a new tab because of, uh, same site stuff or extreme options.
Right. So we pop open a new tab and then we send a post message from our attacker controlled page to our, our victim page. Right. Yeah. Um, and the, in order for us to send, they have to be in the same browser context group, which is why we, we open it up and we get a frame reference. Um, and then we can do frame reference dot post message. And that's how we send it.
This son of a gun coop here severs that frame reference. So whenever I pop up in a new tab, if that new tab, you know, site.com, uh, has the coop header and it says coop, um, same origin or same origin allow popups.
Then, um, when I try to access that window, you know, that I opened up by window.open, it's going to say no. It severs that relationship. Right. Yeah.
So there's no freaking way Joseph to send a post message to that page. And I have a zero day right now.
How many bugs do you have that are, that are blocked by that?
Dude, it's actually figured out a way around it. Um, and which I'll, I'll explain, which is great. Um, but there, there, this will really, really inhibit a lot of post message related bugs. And, but, but there is an upside to this too, dude, which is that you can tell companies that don't want to pay for like third party library vulnerabilities.
Like that I have post message that they have a remediation method, which is they can put cross origin opener policy on their page.
And then there's no way to send a post message through. Right. And so it's sort of a double edged sword, right?
You can use it to pay sometimes. Cause you can, yeah, yeah.
Because they have a mitigation.
You can give a fix. Yeah.
Exactly. Um, so that it's a little bit of a double edged sword in that regard, but, um, essentially what it does is it severs the, the relationship between your attacker page and the victim page.
Uh, and there's no way to communicate, um, by a post message between those two.
Now, let me kind of talk about the nuances of this, this bad boy for a second.
Okay. So one, and this is the big one.
It only affects top level pages.
Okay.
So if you can, so let's say you've got a, a vulnerability on www.site.com.
Right.
Um, if you can get www.site.com, iframed into a page that does not have coop headers, right?
So let's say, you know, iframe.site.com, iframe's in www.site.com.
Right.
If iframe.site.com does not have a coop header, then you can do a window.open to iframe.site.com and then it will iframe www.site.com.
And then you can send a message from your attacker control page through, through iframe.site.com to the page.
Yeah, exactly.
And so even, even though www.site.com has the coop header, it's going to be ignored because it's not a top level page.
Right.
Um, and so you still will have that frame reference and can send that data through.
Um, and, and so here's the place where, I mean, this, this is the major, the major workaround that, that the team, you know, uh, the, the research lab team that was kind of talking about, um, these concepts, uh, shared, uh, which is that if you can figure out a way to get it, uh, iframe in, then that's kind of your best way to exploit this.
And, uh, and I'll just share from my own personal hacking experience that it is easier to get an iframe injection.
Um, you know, when you are dealing with some third party libraries.
Right.
And so oftentimes what will happen is like a site will have a third party library.
It'll like iframe in some like support page or like some page or something like that.
And then if you can get an XSS on that page on, on that, then you can reach through redirecting the page.
If you can get it, this is how it works.
So like you've, I'm getting, I'm getting crazy now guys, listen closely.
Cause this one's going to be tricky.
Okay.
So you get an XSS on the, on the, the, you know, support, support.com.
Right.
And so you, you get the XSS on support.com.
You, I, you, I framed that into your attacker page.
Right.
Um, so now you've got control of support.com in your attacker page.
Then you, you open up a window to, uh, uh, the page that has the, the, uh, I, I, I, I,
for support.com.
Right.
And then you reach from your attacker controlled, you know, XSS, and you reach over through the,
the page that you can't into the iframe on the victim page.
And then you redirect that to the page that has the coop headers.
I subsided that that's even possible.
Do you see what I'm saying?
And then now it now, yeah.
Cause you have the XSS it's same origin.
So you can do redirects and then, and now you've got the page that has the coop headers embedded in iframe.site.com.
And then you can communicate to that page via, via post message and then pop your XSS or whatever.
So it's a little convoluted, but, um, it really, it really does work.
And it's the best way that I've found to get around coop headers.
Go hack on things.
You're not supposed to go find XSS on third parties.
Leverage the third party trust relationship.
Yeah.
I prefer to call it.
There you go.
Yep.
And you're doing it for responsible reason and just closing it and it's fine.
But yes, no, I agree.
I think, I think that's really cool.
And I'm, I'm shocked that I was able to follow that.
Hopefully the listeners can too, but yeah, basically on your attacker page, if you get XSS, you can iframe that support.com.
Yeah.
And influence the iframe of support.com on the, on the company's website, which allows you to redirect it.
Dude, that's great.
All right, dude, I'm glad you're able to track with that.
I don't know if that's you being big brain or my explanation being sufficient, but some combination of the two.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
Okay.
So let me mention this other piece of this.
Yep.
Coop is also, it's called cross origin opener policy, but it actually has, it affects the opener and the opened, right?
So if you can get a, like whatever site.com to open a popup window, it will also have a severed relationship if the, if the coop header is in place.
Well, actually, yeah.
So let's, let's tell the listener real quick.
What are the options for that header?
The value.
Okay.
Great.
Thank you.
Specification there.
So there are three values for that.
They're same origin, which means, um, only sites of the same origin can have that opener relationship, right?
Okay.
There's same origin allows popups, which I'll explain.
And then there's unsafe, none or missing, which is like the default value when it's not there.
Okay.
So same origins.
That's great.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, so same origin allow popups is the, the nuanced one.
Okay.
So essentially what happens with that one is like, you can't have any relationship.
Excuse me.
You can't have any relationship with the page beforehand, but if that page opens up a popup
to like your attacker controlled page, then that page will have a reference to the other,
the page with the coop headers, um, because it's a popup from the page with the coop headers.
Right?
So if you can get it to pop up a window, then you will be able to access that, get a frame reference to that window via window.opener.
Okay.
Um, so that's another sort of workaround.
It's a little bit more rare for you to be able to get a popup like that.
Um, you kind of need like a popup injection, or maybe there's like some page where they forgot to do like, um, where they had like a, like an href, you know, pointing to it.
And they didn't put like no refer or anything like that.
Um, but if you can get that to happen, then you can be able to trigger the attack back on that same page that has the coop headers.
Does that make sense?
Or am I, it does a little bit.
Yes.
I've, I've not, I've never even heard of popup injection.
So yeah, well, it's, it, I just, there's a good reason for that.
I just, I just invented it on the spot, but, um, yeah, you know, controlling where, you know, what window or what location.
It seems pretty, it seems pretty rare.
Like you said, I've never seen same site allow popups, so it's not really a, a very relevant situation.
Um, but I figured I would add that nuance in there.
Um, just in case.
Cool.
Okay.
So two other, so that's coop pain in the ass, severs the frame relationship solution is if it has allowed popups, try to get a popup.
And if it doesn't have a lot of popups, if it's just same origin, then you need to get that page.
I framed into a page that, that is same origin, but does not have a coop header, which is really, which is tricky, you know?
So you gotta understand where your application segments are and get that iframe injection.
And once I'll, I'll just add there, there is no same site setting for this.
So it has to be exactly same origin.
Um, and, and so my, my example was a little bit flawed.
It can't be iframe.site.com.
It has to be www.site.com.
Iframe in www.site.com.
Um, it, which, which does make it more difficult, but was the situation when I actually exploited it.
Um, uh, and so just, just understand.
So probably large companies with a lot of functionality under a main domain is where you would have to find that.
Yeah, exactly.
And there, there, there will be different application segments as well, right?
Where there's like, okay, slash whatever is one app and then slash blah, blah, blah is another app, right?
That's right.
Um, so that's the sort of situation we're looking at.
Um, okay.
Two more headers to go.
These would be a lot less, um, a lot less nuanced.
We have cross origin and better policy.
Okay.
This one, um, this one is kind of exactly what it sounds like.
It's a policy on what can be embedded into the page.
Okay.
So the default value for that is unsafe none, or if it's missing, then that's unsafe, unsafe none.
And there's two other values, um, require corp, which I'll explain in just a second.
And then credential lists, which is any resource that you have embedded in the page will be sent with zero cookies.
You know, your images, whatever.
And this is a little bit less of a big thing now that we've got same site cookies, that cookies aren't really sent anyway, unless they, unless they are, you know, top level navigations.
Yeah.
Um, but, uh, if this is something that you're running into and you do need to have, um, those on there, um, then you're, you're kind of screwed.
Um, so just be aware of those three values and then going back to the other one, which is required corp.
What does required corp do?
Good, good question.
Let me, let me explain that.
So require corp says any, any asset that is being embedded in this page has to return the, the cross origin resource policy.
Okay.
And if it doesn't, then it's blocked.
And the cross origin resource policy header, unlike these other two headers and better policy and opener policy, which are embedded on the page.
This resource policy, uh, header has to be embedded on the asset that is being loaded.
Okay.
I feel like this is a, that's a kind of a pit paradigm that could be applied.
Like that kind of like a meta paradigm that could be applied for security and other places.
It makes me think it's like a really neat concept that you want to like, go ahead and, um, pre-approve or put on an allow list.
Thanks from other places.
And so what you do is you put it in the, in the body or the header of the thing that's coming in.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting.
It's very thorough.
It's very, it's very dependent depth.
I just DM'd you a link.
This is like to, um, uh, Google user content.com.
Um, which is where they like host user content for Google.
Yeah.
You notice there, their, their cross origin resource policy says, says cross origin, which is the most permissive setting.
So there's three settings, same site, same origin and cross origin.
So this is particularly helpful if you are looking to prevent an asset that you have from being embedded on an attacker controlled page.
And, um, there's a specific class of vulnerabilities that is all but gone now, but, but does still sort of exist called cross site, um, XSSI cross site script injection.
Yeah.
And I don't know if you, you were in the like front end game when this class of vulnerability existed, but essentially how this works is on an attacker controlled page, you do a script tag and you include a dynamically generated script on the target website.
Mm-hmm.
That leaks data about the current user's authenticated state.
And then when it loads that script into your page, you can do some JavaScript shit to pull out the data and get access to it.
Right.
And so this kind of got deleted when, when same site, uh, lacks became the default.
But, um, uh, if, if the author is being done off of same site, none cookies and the script is being dynamically generated off those cookies, then it could be something that could still happen.
So, you know, anytime you see dynamically generated scripts, you should be, be thinking about that.
Yeah.
Um, but this is the cross origin resource policy is a great way to prevent this from happening.
So you can take that script, add the cross origin resource policy header to it and say, Hey, cross origins, uh, set it to same site or same origin.
Cross origin is not allowed to load this, this resource.
Right.
And then that would block that excess high from occurring because the attacker could not include your dynamically generated script tag on their page.
Does that make sense?
Does the browser just like straight up refuse it?
Yeah.
It says, no, we're not going to let them load this resource because they don't have.
That's cool.
So it's pretty solid.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's, so if you implement all three of those headers correctly, then the JavaScript Boolean cross origin isolated will be set to true.
Um, and then you're, you get access to a bunch of like super secure timing APIs and stuff like that, that you can get access to that, that Spectre was utilizing to leak, leak a bunch of stuff.
Um, so I just wanted to give those to the listeners and kind of say, Hey, this is kind of what we've got, uh, as far as these cross origin headers go on like cross origin and better policy and cross origin resource policy are not super helpful.
Um, for an attacker, but understanding the nuances of coop are absolutely necessary.
Um, and I think that workaround that the research lab came up with, with like getting it embedded into a page is super helpful for exploiting these sorts of scenarios.
Yeah.
I mean, I, I doubt there are very many people who have figured that out.
And so there's probably a lot of those lying around where it seemed unexploitable, but there actually is now a path to exploitation.
Yeah.
So shout out to, to the, the team.
I'm it, it warms the heart a little bit to see some, some, uh, some good research coming out of the research lab already.
Um, it is an investment we're doing and, uh, we've already seen, I think several volumes get popped from the research lab.
And then also this, this nice piece of research getting pumped out to the pod.
So appreciate you guys on the, on the research lab.
100%.
Um, okay, dude, hang in there.
I got two more headers I want to tell you about.
Perfect.
Okay.
So these are not related to cross origin stuff, but I just kind of wanted to, since we're talking about web headers, I kind of wanted to like throw these in there just as a bonus.
The next two are service worker allowed and X content type options.
So I'm glad you have a service worker allowed on there.
I know you have mentioned service worker stuff a lot in the past and I'm not, you know, super up to date on like how it works and like what volumes are possible there, but you see it all over the place these days.
So I'm curious.
Um, yeah.
What you have to say about this.
So service workers, for those of you that aren't familiar is essentially a way for you to, I'm going to explain this from such an attacker perspective.
Like literally what I was about to say was a way for you to gain persistence in the browser, right?
Service workers are not that service workers are something to help with caching and like a bunch of other stuff like that.
In the browser, but from an attacker perspective, from a hackers perspective, it's a way for you to gain persistence in a victim's browser.
Okay.
So the way this typically works is you have to have file upload.
You have to be able to upload a JS file and you've got to be able to upload an HTML file or have an XSS.
Okay.
Cool.
Um, and once you do that, you can register a service worker and that service worker is scoped to whatever path you have that the, the JS file and the, the XSS on.
So if you're, you know, if your JS file is under, you know, slash site slash assets slash upload, then your service worker is only going to be able to access slash sites.
I'll ask just a slash upload and affect the pages that are being loaded in the victim's browser thereafter at those paths.
Yep.
So, um, but it's pretty cool if you can get it installed at slash, then you just essentially have persistent XSS on every single page in the browser, which is awesome.
Yeah.
I was going to say, I guess that means that many service workers are probably implemented at root because they need to be able to run across a majority of the website.
So if you're able to attack a service worker, that's a really interesting scope too, because if you're able to, to hijack, um, then I imagine there's a lot of stuff you can do there.
Yeah.
I do know that it's a little bit tricky and I do know that the research lab is doing some research on the, that right now.
Um, but very, very ripe scope.
Um, however, so, you know, that path thing really kind of gets into the, it gets, it gets to become a problem because it's not that rare that we can upload like a JavaScript file or an HTML file to a target.
Right. That's pretty standard. Um, but you know, it's normally at some like obscure path that has our ID in it.
If we register a service worker there, then it doesn't really do anything.
Right.
Um, uh, and so there's this header that's very interesting called service worker allowed, and it's an HTTP response header that contains a path that the service worker should be scoped to.
So even if your JS file is at like, you know, slash assets, slash user, my user ID, slash whatever dot JS.
If you can figure out a way to return the service worker allowed header and say service worker allowed colon slash, right.
Then, um, it will just trust it.
It trusts it and it will give the service worker, uh, permission to access anything under slash.
Cool.
Right. Which is, which is great.
So here's the, here's where the rubber meets the road on this one.
I just want to make people aware of this, uh, because I know Franz has done a lot of really cool stuff in there in Matan as well.
Um, related to using service workers to leak like private, um, like signed, uh, signed header or signed like query parameters to access like a specific file and that sort of thing.
Um, and I think this is really help helpful for those sort of scenarios, but it's pretty rare that you can control an HTTP response header.
Um, and there's two sort of main configurations where I can think that that, that would be happening.
And that is it with CRLF injection, right?
If you can get a CRLF injection, then you can insert this header, um, and get the XSS and generate the JS file, which is pretty rad.
Um, or more likely in a scenario where the app allows you to configure a reverse proxy back to your own site.
Okay.
And I wanted to sort of shout out the specific, um, functionality in Shopify, um, called app proxies.
Uh, and essentially it allows you to do just that proxy, a specific path on a store that you've installed an application on back to your website.
Um, and, and so, you know, typically you could return the service worker allowed header, and that would allow you to register a service worker, which would gain you control of the whole, my Shopify.
Uh, website, but they have a list of disallowed headers that can come through this reverse proxy and service worker allowed is on that.
So if anybody can figure out a way to smuggle a service worker allowed header through this app proxy, then that's a really cool piece of scope.
Um, and any other scenarios, any other targets where there's like an app proxy like functionality where you're doing a reverse proxy.
Um, uh, there is a really ripe attacks scenario there with, with service workers, um, being able to take over that whole origin, not just the origin that you're scoped to, uh, for the reverse proxy.
So why does Shopify have this?
If you've done one, I don't know, man.
I I'll, I'll give a full disclaimer, you know, um, I would be careful reporting bugs on this scope.
You know, um, uh, I know that there are some, some weird quirks with this specific piece of scope, but I just wanted to use it as an example because, um, uh, it's, it's pretty funky functionality.
Uh, and I think there's a lot of areas where that can cause problems.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to think through, like, if I understood why Shopify added it, then I'll be able to like, kind of update on mental model for what other companies, what other programs would maybe have a similar functionality.
I think, you know, Shopify is really built on plugins.
So I think you see this type of functionality in any area where, um, you know, there's app hosting or there's like third party plugins that really need to be seamlessly integrated into the main app.
Those sort of scenarios are where you probably.
Maybe Atlassian and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Atlassian might have something similar.
I want to say I saw something on or so, um, those, those bigger, those giant apps, you know, often have this functionality sort of buried in there related to the app functionality.
Yeah, definitely.
All right.
Cool.
Last one.
Dude, my, my throat is getting a little scratchy again.
I don't know.
I've had this cold for like a week.
Uh, it just won't go away.
Yeah.
I heard it.
I heard it come through once or twice, but you've been good.
Yeah.
All right.
So last one here, X content options, um, has one, one available, um, sort of parameter that you can give it, which is no sniff.
Okay.
And have you heard of this one before Joseph?
Do you know what this one does?
I don't, but I have seen it many, many times.
Yes.
So essentially what it does is, uh, the browser will attempt to sniff the content type of the page that is being returned if a content type header is not provided.
Okay.
And so this one says, don't freaking do that, uh, is what it says.
Right.
Um, cause that a lot of XSS is occur from can occur from that sort of content type sniffing, or even as we've learned recently, um, character set sniffing can cause a lot of issues.
So this says, don't do that.
Just, just don't.
Okay.
And, um, I just wanted to get, tell the community about this one little nuance that I stumbled upon, um, not too long ago, which is that if you repeat the content type options header twice, let's say you've got a CRLF injection and your injection is below the content type, um, options header and below the content type header.
Right.
So you can't overwrite those two headers.
What you can do is you can add another X content types header with a, with a invalid value.
And the browser will be like, ah, dude, there's two, there's two content type options headers.
Uh, what do I do?
I'm, I'm gonna, I'm gonna sniff.
I got, I got a sniff.
You know, the browser is just really eager to sniff for some reason.
Um, and so if you provide two of these content type options headers, they will actually discard both of them, uh, and allow the browser to actually sniff.
The content type from the data that's being returned.
So it's a pretty, that's amazing.
Yeah, man.
So this, uh, this content type options header, it's really funky.
Why would a browser just drop it?
If there's two, it's like, just take one at least.
That's what they do for most other headers.
But I think this is also a really like interesting area of research where this one content type options header behaves this way.
I wonder if there's the other headers that sort of have a similar functionality.
Yeah.
Um, so that's, that's something that's on the research list for the research lab.
And, and maybe the community can kind of poke at it as well.
Yeah.
It's so easy to now, I think you mentioned this to me recently to have AI spin up like little dock containers of things that like, you know, servers that respond in weird ways.
For example, it'd be really interesting to like, have it do that with a bunch of different duplicate headers and see how browsers respond.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Definitely a cool, cool and really easily done piece of research.
I think like that could easily be knocked out in eight hours and you could like write something up and it'd be really.
And you get featured on the podcast.
It'd be great.
Yeah.
Let us know.
Send it, send it to us guys.
Drop it in the cool research section.
If you do it, um, and we'll cover it on the pod.
Um, okay.
Um, one little thing that I just wanted to close with dude.
So you've seen the refer header, right?
That's like super common course.
A million times.
Yeah, dude.
I, I've always thought there was something funky about the refer header.
Like I, I sometimes, you know, there's like C-Serve protections or whatever, and you're like checking something and it says, oh, you know, don't have the refer header.
And then I type refer and I give it a refer and it says, don't have the refer header.
And I'm like, ah, I misspelled refer.
You know, there's only one R.
No, no, there's two R's dude.
Refer the, the refer header that is always sent in the browser.
Every time you make a request contains a misspelling of the word refer refer is spelled R E F E R R E R.
That's right.
The one that the browser actually sends is R E F E R E R.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I came across this randomly.
Someone else mentioned it as like a little tidbit or like, did you know about web security like a few years ago?
But it's really funny and mind blowing.
I love like any kind of little quirks of old systems.
I think about that a lot of video games.
I know a lot of our listeners probably game, but I think it's really like just neat and a really cool byproduct of the fact that some small dev team made some decision 15 years ago.
And now like two, you know, 2 million people are like playing this game where they're over optimizing to find that one item that the developer didn't think about.
When they actually added an attribute that was overpowered or something, you know, like I think it's really cool to have those downstream effects.
And it feels similar here.
It's like some developer misspelled it.
And at some point it was way too embedded in all the systems to like.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So it makes me feel good.
Like, you know, these people, these core people that built the whole end.
This is what I'm talking about.
Like when I said on the pod a couple of weeks ago, like the people that built all these crazy specs and these cool, like crazy protocols and stuff like that.
They're just humans.
Just like, you know, like there's no need to be so intimidated from all of this.
If some, some bro in his basement built this protocol, you can figure it out in like, you know, 10 times as much time as he took.
So it's not going to be beyond your grasp, but you're not just incapable of, of learning this.
You can, it just takes time.
So, and people like those bros misspell the word refer and then the whole internet has to use this misspelling for the rest of the time the internet exists.
So yeah, I feel like usually the stuff that's like hard to understand or confusing is mostly due to like naming conventions or like the fact that our brains kind of conflate two topics or two subjects.
Yeah.
So as soon as you like can properly classify it, even as you were describing that thing that I grok the first time with the windows and all that, I feel like having like just a mental, a physical mental view of what actually is occurring.
I even noticed you kind of do it when you draw it out with your hands and you say it goes over and then it goes down.
Yeah, exactly.
It's like these like spatial references really help understand front end hacks like front end.
Oh yeah.
Oh, for sure, dude.
And that's, that's why we try to always draw it out when we're doing the master classes in the critical thinkers discord and stuff like that to try to give people a tangible method.
You know, you got, you got auditory learners, you got visual learners, you got kinesthetic learners.
I think we over leverage, you know, on the, on the kinesthetic learners.
Cause we're hackers who like to get our hands on the keyboard and tweak with stuff.
But there's a lot of people that are learned by, by audio, the podcast or visual, you know, watching something or seeing a graph drawn.
You just got to figure out which way you learn best and then try to get the content into that medium for you, which is why we also released the podcast via text with the hacker notes.
So, so people that learn better by reading can ingest the same content and get the value out.
So yeah, yeah, exactly.
And you know, using AI, you can kind of swap between those, those modalities a little bit, a little bit more seamlessly these days.
So yeah, for sure, man.
All right.
You got anything else to add or is that a wrap on the pod?
No, I think that's it.
I appreciate it.
I'm going to go try to find my first bug on day one, a full-time bug bounty.
So dude, GG, go get it, man.
All right.
Peace.
See ya.
Bye.
And that's a wrap on this episode of Critical Thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord.
Join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access
to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us.
We'll see you there.